everyone this is Jerry and this is
another live let's gain much but a seek
out for three minute and five minute
game for nineteen hundred plus players
okay this is a game against that's 1967
let's try the try the Polish opening and
I haven't played this before he seems to
already be in pre move mode yeah this is
the extent of my knowledge by the way
for the Polish opening be for Bishop b2
that's it alright so let's try and get
all of my pieces out eventually this
pawn is gonna find itself under fire
after the pawn move so might as well do
that now sort of like a King's Indian
set up here get this type of move in I
believe I take or maybe maybe I go for
like a double fianchetto let's try this
so this is a three minute game that
we're playing here so he's ready to win
upon and I guess I'll take right now
Bishop here eventually I'll have a pawn
push if he takes what is night I have to
worry about night here that's so sure I
won't I'm worried about this so there's
pressure here in conjunction with the
night here but I'll be able to castle in
time if you were to play move like that
an IG for Castle and I'm protecting f2
just in just in time so maybe night here
night here now my my bishop is able to
exert pressure on the position now c-4
would probably a purposeful move
striking in the center and taking
advantage that this pawn is pinned from
moving or capturing as a result of this
Bishop being unprotected so probably
just retreat here here's pressure
against this pawn that's fairly easily
prevented like if I wanted to just
release the pressure here I could play
here I think so maybe they hear pawn
push upon c4
lob different pawn choices h3 I think I
think h3 I'm not so sure I like having
this this night here
maybe you know let's kick this night out
of here maybe maybe I'll end up taking
takes takes and then being a pin for a
little bit alright and now I'll go with
this taking advantage of this pin just
trying to break down his center sort of
a it's like a hyper in the hyper modern
approach you give your opponent the
center and then you try and use it
against them you you strike at that
Center so maybe palm push here to here
try and open up the a file my bishop is
I think both of my bishops are
functioning pretty well here I think I
let's see still continue with this if he
takes every capture with my knight I
capture him or allow him to capture me
let's go with this I don't want my king
to be vulnerable to checks if he pushes
I could take this Knight he might do
pawn push I know
pawn push I could take this tonight my
pawn right here is unprotected as a
result of this pin on my F two pawns so
I have to watch out for that I already
take here at least I'm open opening up
this Queen here it's opposite the King
it's opposite the Queen the Queen is
unprotected if here I don't have to
react to the pawn attacking my knight
just yet so what to do push here I think
this is sensible yeah here and then here
so it seems like I'm blocking in my
bishop but this move is actually made
with a deeper meaning I'm actually
intending on coming here
yeah so this product could be very
annoying from this square and that could
always push forward if if this capture
does occur
I can always push forward here at some
point actually I'm threatening to win
upon so this is actually a very
aggressive move I have an open file here
he missed that I could just win this
poem yeah he's in rough shape yeah it
was just a blunder there and it's so how
to I don't win this game I think I just
grabbed this guy yeah so all right I'm
out material it's just a matter when in
the game from here yeah so actually
where did where the mistake a car before
again this is right there's the extent
of my knowledge in this opening be for
Bishop b2 and he was in pre movement
that beats and b6 came like
automatically he was gonna play that no
matter what I played is my first move so
this move was just made to eventually he
was going to come under fire and what I
kind of have here is a Kings Indian sort
of setup I'm not sure if this is the
correct recapture factors back up I
think maybe taking that the pawn might
be a good choice as well having another
pawn like a knight pawn become a bishop
on that way that Bishop on can
contribute to controlling central
squares as a result so castle castle and
they here I think was important if I
don't play here he could he might be
able to push forward and then once it's
here I always have to worry about the
pawn coming here so after I made that my
knight move so my bishop come out back
and I was being Knight was attacking
that Bishop and right here this is
actually a point where I had like a few
different choices I was thinking maybe
night here pawn here pawn here this
seems like an automatic move at some
point but I thought it was fast to take
that Knight first
yeah and in this position I think it's
better to take on this square have him
recapture and then go forth with the
recapture of this this pawn here because
if I were to take right here now he
could take I have to recapture my King
is then susceptible to checks along this
diagonal so I want to avoid that and
maybe here this was necessary I don't
think it's enough that's right this pawn
is still hanging so he had to do
something about this so this Knight is
actually very well placed and this is a
this turned out to be the winner right
here pretty much this combo of my knight
in queen focusing on f7 so I'm not sure
what else to really be doing is is black
here he has to worry about the defense
of this pawn hizmet his major pieces are
tied down to the defense of this pawn so
maybe pawn here at some point but right
now it's not good because my queen is
opposite it so maybe Queen here might
have been better maybe in that shirts I
think I'm in a better position here and
after my knight comes here I believe he
has to take and have to recapture it's
equal material he has a passed pawn I
still have moves like pond here at some
point maybe opening up this diagonal at
a favorable point but he ended up just
blundering Bishop there was just a
blunder you probably had to maybe defend
like this or just take my knight so
after her Queen takes and that was the
end of the game but I hope you got
something out of this game in as always
comments and questions are appreciated
thanks so much
bye